return now to one of those main stories
this lunch time the family of Zara Alina
who was killed last summer have
criticized the probation service for the
way they handled the release from prison
of her killer in a damning report out
today the Chief Inspector of probation
highlighted a series of errors in the
handling of Jordan McSweeney today Zara
Alina's Aunt phara's Naz spoke about the
failings
the report is extremely distressing
but it's not holding back on any punches
it's very clear
clearly laid out a Litany of errors
serious errors
and recommendations which have been
presented before what we have is
an incompetent probation service
there is some
element of
um
poor resources and inadequately
inadequate funding and inadequate
Staffing
but the report lays out
incompetencies on senior level on
management level on Frontline level
inadequate and
incorrect assessment
so he was assessed as medium risk
when he should have been assessed as
high risk
and although probation were lacking in
intelligence from prison
why I don't know and that's not clear
either in the report so there is another
dark area that needs light shine upon it
what is going on the prison staff to not
communicate with community staff in
probation
especially with somebody who has spent
the bulk of his adult life in prison so
all the Intelligence on him is in prison
and they're not shared with Community
stuff one of the staff members in the
report is quoted as saying I didn't have
time to read about his history
which tells me either the history is
really badly written you know is it
written in some kind of long hand essay
format instead of okay this is the list
of offenses and all we have to do is it
takes it takes us 10 seconds to look at
those list of offenses even though
they're very long and to be able to spot
that he is high risk and the report lays
out he should have been assessed as high
risk he was actually given a license
to go ahead and do whatever he wanted
and he knew that because this is a
system that he knows
and this is what happens with offenders
they know the system they know that
they're going to go out and disappear
they know that they're not going to be
found so they know they can do anything
so this whole system is pointless
handing doing an assessment is pointless
if you don't know how what for if you
don't know
how you're going to follow up with the
assessment